[Music]
hello good evening
uh
we've got a whole space over here and
nobody's sitting i just thank you denise
for holding down the fort over here on
this side
welcome welcome to the table my name is
karen miner so glad you're with us
tonight on this october evening
um yeah like weather's starting to
change i love fall
i love fall and speaking of fall
i just have one announcement tonight
and it's about halloween halloween falls
on a sunday this year
and so we thought why not use
sunday of halloween to
just celebrate our kids at the kids
table and uh so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna do a trunk or treat that
night we're gonna forego our usual time
in here together and take it outside and
do a fun trunk or treat event uh for our
kids and so it will start at five
o'clock just like we do usually in here
and for this to be successful and fun
for our kids
we need to have people that are willing
to open their trunk
of their car and decorate it and have
some candy it does not need to be
anything fancy or elaborate although
that would be great too
but don't let it intimidate you you just
need to have a trunk that you can just
open and have candy like candy is the
main attraction let's be real so
as long as you've got the trunk you've
got the candy kids are going to be very
happy uh
hmm
oh yeah costumes costumes are fun we
encourage the costumes okay that's gonna
be the costume police yeah did you come
in costume
so
uh yeah for that i believe we have a
sign up in the back where you can sign
up your trunk
to have candy in it and all of that good
stuff the table will be providing food
and drinks so we want to make it easy on
our families to just show up with your
kids in costume you can dress up as well
and we'll just have a fun night together
sound good
all right so hope to see you for that
secondly
today is world mental health day
and tomorrow is coming out day
and so i just wanted to acknowledge
those two very very important days
and
gosh
who hasn't
struggled with mental health either
yourself or people around you during
this pandemic it's been a rough two
years
and
my thought is
at church both for mental health issues
as well as for for those that have
either already come out who are lgbtq
allies who have come out or in the
process of coming out or those that have
chosen not to come out
church should be a place that is welcome
for all of you
no matter what and a place that is
accepting wherever you're at on that
spectrum
and so
as we worship tonight as we gather
tonight i just want to be really really
clear that that's our heart at the table
is that whatever you walk in with
it's welcome here you don't have to
check it at the door you don't have to
wear a mask
a metaphorical mask to come in here and
worship you can be 100
freely yourself whether you are feeling
great or this is one of your lowest days
and one of the songs we're going to sing
talks about god being there in every
high and every low and i can i can tell
you that is true that is so true so i
hope you receive that tonight
and i hope that you are
willing to be brave to be fully yourself
here at church and in other spaces as
well so let's pray
god thank you so much for your presence
thank you for your grace your
unconditional love your acceptance
and that we get to be here together in
this building online that we can connect
and remember who you are that you are
love that you are with us
and that we are not alone
so god as we worship tonight help us to
remember those truths
god speak to our hearts
and continue to reveal yourself who you
are
and help us to remember that we are
yours
in jesus name
amen
thanks karen
it is great to be with you guys um
welcome to this time we're gonna get
started with some music and you guys are
invited to stand with us and sing along
clap
or
engage all of your senses so
i love that worship is not just about us
singing words but it's really about
engaging
the love of god and his nature and his
creativity together as a community so i
just encourage you if you are one of
those people who feels comfortable
lifting your hands do that so that
you're engaging your physical body
because he created it and he meets us
there in it if you're someone who likes
to sit and reflect on the words and take
that in you are also welcome to do that
however you meet with god come and meet
with him during this time all right
so gary's going to get us started with
this song so you all sing along as you
feel comfortable
[Music]
we dream of you
on city streets
breathing again
[Music]
we dream of you
at kitchen scene
[Music]
we are children
of grace
[Music]
oh
leaving behind
flickering screens
to be together again
[Music]
we are children
is
[Music]
let the people
is
[Music]
let the people sing the songs
children
of grace
[Music]
is
rejoice
that the
[Music]
let earth people sing the songs
let the people sing the songs
[Music]
rivers from
[Applause]
[Music]
love it all right let's do i am set free
you broke my chains
of sin and shame and you covered me with
grace
you meant my life with your holy fire
you cover me with grace
you are the hand who reaches out to say
i am set free
[Music]
it is for freedom
that i
am
set
free
[Music]
you broke my chains of
and shame and you covered me
with
[Music]
you grace
me with grace
you are the hand that reaches out to say
i am set free
[Music]
it is for freedom
that i am
set
free
and i am set free
i am
[Music]
it is for freedom
that i am set
free
[Music]
yes lord we are grateful
for your grace and for your love
[Music]
lord we are grateful
for your grace and for your love
yes lord we are grateful
you are the hand that reaches out to
save
[Music]
it is for freedom
that i am
set
free
i am separated
[Music]
it is for freedom
that i
am set free
i am set free
[Music]
tonight we're going to move into our
prayer of the people and if this is your
first time with us
um this is something that's been passed
down through christian history and it's
just a time for us to offer up short
prayers together and to carry one
another's burdens to be present and make
room and space for the things that we're
carrying in our lives and our hearts so
if there's someone on your heart tonight
or a situation on your heart that you
would like to offer up in this time we
believe together that we are here as a
community to shoulder each other's
burdens and also that god is present
with us in the things that we carry so
i'm gonna read part of this prayer and
then i'll leave space for you guys to
share a name or situation
that's on your heart and if you're
online we would encourage you to engage
this by leaving a comment and
karen is going to have the mic and
she'll read any comments that are left
online so that we can all
engage with you guys as well um during
this time and then i'll close it out
with a short prayer at the end
jesus for the city of saxi texas and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick for the widow
and the orphan for the injured and the
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed and the unemployed and
the destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember them and care for them
we pray to you
and lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us and so right now we
lift these names and situations
up to you
terry
do
[Music]
from online nancy's chemo treatments
pat's family
teachers and educators
adam's mom to recover quickly from covid
yes
patty and katie and courtney kelly
for these names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence god
amen
[Music]
the lord is my shepherd
i lack nothing
he makes me lie down in green pastures
he leads me beside a quiet waters he
refreshes my soul
he guides me along the right paths for
his name's sake even though i walk
through the darkest valley i will fear
no evil
for you are with me
your rod and your staff
they comfort me
you prepare a table before me in the
presence of my enemies you anoint my
head with oil my cup overflows surely
your goodness and love will follow me
all the days of my life
and i will dwell in the house of the
lord forever
[Music]
even though i walk through the valley
of the shadow of death
your perfect love is casting out fear
even when i'm caught
in the middle
of the storms of this alive
i won't
[Music]
is
me
whom then shall i fear whom then shall i
fear see you never let go
oh no you never let go through the calm
and through the storm oh no you never
let go
[Music]
i can see a light that is coming
for the heart that holds on
a glorious light beyond all compared
oh
and there will be an end to these
troubles but until that day comes
i'll live to know you here on the earth
whom
[Music]
oh
lord you never let go of me
[Music]
sing that one more time
oh no you never let go through the cold
and through the storm oh no you never
let go
[Music]
and i can see a light
that is coming
for the heart that holds on
and there will be an end to these
troubles
[Music]
for the heart that holds on
and there will be an end to these
troubles
but until that day comes
till i will praise you
still i
[Music]
you never let go of me
let's just sing that out with our voices
oh no you never let go through the
coming through the storm oh no you'd
never let go
[Music]
me
god thank you that whatever it is that
we are walking through right now
whatever other people in our life are
going through
god you are enough your grace is enough
your goodness
finds us in the middle of our pain your
light breaks through our darkest moments
and you carry us god you walk with us
through the valley
thank you for not forsaking us for not
running away
for not being afraid of our mess and our
problems
thank you for sticking with us
thank you for carrying us through
and would we be your hands and feet to
the world around us god would we carry
the burdens of others would we shoulder
each other's pain and see one another
through god
[Music]
would we be the first to recognize your
light and your life in people that
others have despised would we be the
first to call out your goodness and your
promise in their broken stories god
would we carry the hope of jesus inside
us
and offer it to the world around us
we believe that you're here and that
you're with us and that you love us god
thank you for who you are
would you meet us tonight wherever we're
at
we trust you to do that we know that you
have in the past and that you'll
continue to do it in the future god
thank you for this time together thank
you for these people and this community
it's in jesus name that we pray
amen
[Music]
thank you guys so much y'all can be
seated and as you do go ahead and turn
to someone around you and welcome them
say hello
[Music]
all right
well guys
um i am obviously not brett and brett is
not in the building at all tonight
actually our
middle
our middle child our oldest son
dax turned 10 this past month and for
his birthday he got tickets to his first
dallas cowboy game
so
they are at the cowboy game together and
i was hoping i checked just before i
came here because i made brett like
promise him blood that he would take
pictures for me
i was like i need this in his baby book
but he hasn't sent any yet he promised
so we'll see
but anyways brad is at the cowboy game
today which means that we have the honor
and the great privilege of hearing from
denise mason which i have to say this is
i was thinking
there's a phrase that i learned i don't
know where i heard this i'm sure it's a
quote from someone and i'm not doing
them justice by you know giving them
credit for it but i heard something a
long time ago that said
um
someone told us this when we were youth
pastors they said you know
most people will not remember anything
you said but they will remember how you
made them feel
and
denise you are that plus one
because
the way you make people feel is enough
it's the sermon in and of itself and yet
i remember every sermon i've heard this
woman preach so far i could name them
which
there's only a handful so maybe at some
point that would wear off but so far
so far everything she says sticks with
me because it's not she's not just
offering up a cliche sermon that's not
what she's doing she speaks from her
heart and
from a place of being transformed first
and then sharing how you know what i
mean how she's finding um
god
transforming her and sharing that with
others in the process so
um i think i think you will both love
what she has to say and how she makes
you feel so
denise if you would come i was just
going to pray for her um before she
prays and then we're handing it over to
you so
yeah
um i don't
for those of you who don't know denise
is the pastor of pleasant valley
methodist church so
she's the one who runs all of this and
she's
i'm just teasing
yes so just for context denise um has
been so gracious for her have gotten to
do a couple different swaps back and
forth to fill in for each other in times
like these so it's always like a treat
in both on both sides so absolutely yeah
it's been great well i just thank you so
much for that wonderful introduction i
love being
here thank you
god thank you for denise and lord i ask
that as she speaks um her heart would
continue to just be sensitive to the
message that you have to share tonight
and that you would lead and guide her
words and god that we would get to
receive god give us open hearts to
hear and understand what you're speaking
uniquely through her to us
and it's in your name that i pray amen
thank you maggie
i just am so grateful to be back here
again um brent has been so kind to
preach for me a number of times and my
congregation loves him and i will just
say that greetings from pleasant valley
united methodist church we're
so happy that you all are here on sunday
evenings we absolutely love you and i
hope you know that i hope you know how
welcome you are and how happy we are
that you're here and if you ever don't
feel that come knock on my door because
i want to know
but i'm just very grateful so the
scripture that i chose for tonight is
taken from the gospel of saint matthew
it's chapter 17 verses one through nine
and i think we're going to see it on the
screen here
so here are these words
six days later jesus took with him peter
and james and his brother john and led
them up a high mountain by themselves
and he was transfigured before them and
his face shone like the sun in his
clothes became dazzling white
suddenly there appeared to them moses
and elijah talking with him
then peter said to jesus lord it is good
for us to be here if you wish i will
make three dwellings here one for you
one for moses and one for elijah
while he was still speaking suddenly a
bright cloud overshadowed them and from
the cloud a voice said
this is my son
the beloved
with him i am well pleased listen to him
and when the disciples heard this they
fell to the ground and they were
overcome by fear
but jesus came and touched them saying
get up and do not be afraid
when they looked up they saw no one
except jesus himself alone
as they were coming down the mountain
jesus ordered them
tell no one about the vision
until after the son of man has been
raised from the dead
so this is god's word tonight for god's
people would you pray with me please
come holy spirit come may the words of
my mouth
and the meditations of our hearts be
acceptable in your sight for you are our
rock
and our redeemer
amen
so
i gotta tell you i love the mountains
some people are beach people
some people are you know farm people
there's all kinds of people but i'm a
mountain person
now not the busy ski resort kind of
mountain person but the majestic quiet
mountain person where you can hike and
hike and never see another soul
now it wasn't always this way i have to
tell you because
i'm a missionary kid or i grew up a
missionary kid and from the time of my
early elementary well actually i was
before elementary school up until i was
12 we lived in the country of egypt
so
when i was 12 my parents took on a new
assignment
and we moved to kathmandu nepal
and i think we have a picture of
where's the
there they are
so you can see what is surrounding
kathmandu
mountains nepal is the home of the
himalayas it's got eight
of the ten
highest mountains eight of them are in
the country of nepal
now i'd never really been around
mountains before this because well
egypt enough said
but you can't really be living in nepal
without becoming really familiar with
mountains and i went to a school there
that did twice yearly treks each trek
was two weeks and we would go to places
like helen boo and longtang mustang in
the dalagiri circuit
just to name a few
but but while school trips were fun i
was particularly excited the year i
turned 16
to go on a trek with my dad we were
going to annapurna base camp with my dad
my brother my friend mike who later
became my husband
and his father and along with our sherpa
guides
now i was the only girl on this trek
which i was quite excited about before i
left
before i left
because soon i found out that whenever a
bunch of guys are out in the wild
together well personal hygiene
seems to take a back seat
and i was sleeping in the tent with
these guys
so it was torturous i've just got to
tell you it was torturous and because i
was the only girl i was an easy target
easy target for any kind of teasing they
wanted to do
now
everything it seemed was something for
them to jump on and make fun of me now
not that i was an overly sensitive
teenage girl
because i wasn't
but
in my eyes it seemed like everything i
did
they picked on me
they were the problem
not me
well halfway through this two-week trip
i was feeling very sorry for myself
because earlier in the day you see i
happen to mention that i had been
reading this article
about a tribe in africa that didn't
speak a normal language in fact the only
way they communicated each other was by
whistling to one another
now my brother and my husband-to-be
which i didn't know at that time thank
god
but and i mean that because of what
happened but
they decided that that was the silliest
thing they had ever heard
and they kept challenging me to give me
their give give them my source where did
you hear this how do you know this is
true and when i couldn't and to be
really honest i
i'm pretty stubborn and i dug my heels
in and i you know
i wasn't really quite sure that it was
true but i was going to stand behind it
no matter what
well this amused my brother and mike
so for the rest of the day they only
communicated to each other by whistling
to one another
and anytime i asked them a question they
whistled back at me
so needless to say
yeah i married him anyway i know but
that night i was so angry i could barely
speak i was just so angry i was near
tears so after we set up camp and i
think we have a picture here we set up
camp for the night and you can see how
pretty the place was
i got into the tent and in protest i
decided
i'm not coming out for dinner
i'm going to stay in here all night and
they can worry about me let me just say
they didn't worry about me at all nobody
checked on me
so
in my self-pitying state
i felt like i was all alone in the world
i mean i was surrounded by people
but i felt like they didn't care
anything about me like i was an alien on
a strange planet
and as i lay there i just i just wanted
to go home
back to my mom because i mean after all
she was a girl
she got it
well i pretended to be asleep when they
all came into the tent and
then i lay awake for a very long time
afterwards
and sometime in the early early morning
hours i decided to get up and go sit
outside
it was really really cold and i put on
my down coat and as i stepped out of the
tent the fog was coming out of my mouth
from my breath
and i decided to go sit by the fire
there was not much of a fire there was
just kind of a some embers
there
and i sat there just wishing i was
anywhere
that was far far away from this place
and as i sat well
the full moon rose
over them
over the mountain of annapurna
and i think i have a there's a picture
here yeah so it
as i sat there i'm looking at this full
moon as it gave it silvery light on the
snow and i sat lost in wonder at the
beauty at the majesty of this mountain
and as i did i suddenly felt this peace
come over me a piece like i cannot
describe it was almost a euphoric piece
it was just enveloping me
and the stillness of that moment i felt
the overwhelming presence of god
it was almost as if god was speaking to
me through this beautiful
scenery through this mountain
i sat there for what seemed like forever
it was magnificent and i didn't want
this moment to end but the moon
gradually made its way across the sky
and
the sun started to peak up
and my brother and mike came out of the
tent and began whistling to one another
again
life began
again but i was somehow changed
oh i was still extremely annoyed don't
get me wrong but
i was still a teenage drama queen but
i had experienced in that evening or
that night something profound
although the others my other people
might say that this was brought on by
just being in this beautiful scenery i
know that i encountered god
in that place at that time
now in our text for today
from the gospel of matthew there's no
doubt that peter
james and john have a mountaintop
experience with with god right
they're up close and personal in fact
it's an interesting story it's one that
appears in all three of the synoptic
gospels matthew mark and luke
and it is known as the transfiguration
jesus takes three of his disciples up
this high mountain and when they get to
the top the text tells us that jesus is
transfigured before them
the word used here is metamorphic which
means to undergo a metamorphosis so
jesus changed in front of their eyes his
face shone like the sun and his clothes
became white
as light
and suddenly moses and elijah are there
and they're talking with jesus
moses the the lawgiver and elijah the
prophet who's according according to
malachi is to usher in
the messiah
they're standing there and they're
talking to jesus
it's just a
normal conversation
now i don't know about you but if this
scene was unfolding before my eyes i
think i would have been shocked into
silence
but not peter
peter no he's kind of got the
blabber mouth
and as usual peter has something to say
lord if you wish i will put up three
tents here
three shelters one for moses one for
elijah and one for you
now i always kind of imagine when peter
blurts this out that everybody stops and
does a double take like what
what's wrong with you
but in it's easy to blame peter but in
his defense he's just experienced the
glory of god
and he doesn't want to let it go
it's the pinnacle
this is the pinnacle for him and he
knows it
and if he builds these shelters well he
can come back
he can come back and remember this
moment he can remember the shining face
of jesus he can remember the wonder of
seeing moses and elijah
well sure he knows he has to go back
down the mountain but
he can come back up
he can come back up and remember the
place he experienced god
he can come back up and dwell
on the glory
but before he finishes speaking this
cloud envelops all of them and they hear
a voice this is my son whom i love
with him i am well pleased
listen
to him
now the disciples are terrified and they
they fall to the ground but jesus
taps them on the shoulder
they look up and he tells them come on
don't be afraid
and they get up
and they all head back down the mountain
and on the way jesus prepares them for
what's coming
he tells them he's going to suffer
and as they're hearing this i imagine
peter is really wishing he had been able
to build those three shelters because
now
now he's on a journey that he doesn't
much want to take
from the high of the mountain
peter is now journeying
with
jesus to the cross
maybe you like me have had your own
mountain experience with god that that
time we've felt god's presence in a way
like never before
as i mentioned it's almost euphoric and
it's natural for us to want to stay
there
to stay in that place we don't want to
go back to ordinary times those times we
feel like god is missing
or far away
because it's in the valleys of life
right the valleys of life that we tend
to start doubting
it's in the valleys of life that we have
trouble finding god and we think if we
can only go back up that mountain we're
going to find it again
we're going to meet god there
the sad truth is that
many of us struggle blindly for so much
of our lives trying to recreate that
mountain experience
in
2013 there was an article in the toronto
paper
it's about a woman who woke up and
looked out her window one morning and as
she looked out she happened to notice a
homeless man sleeping on a bench by the
bus stop
she made a mental note of it because
she was hoping that he'd move along
sometime during the day
but the next morning she looked outside
and
was very irritated to notice that the
man was still there he was still
sleeping on the bench
well she thought she would give it one
more day
but when the man was still there the
next day
she'd had enough
this is a nice neighborhood
we don't need homeless people sleeping
on benches around here
so she called the police
there's a homeless guy sleeping on the
bench across the street from me and i
need you to come pick him up right now
make him move to a different area
because i don't want him here
i'd like to keep our neighborhood nice
now a little while later
the police come and they knock on her
door and they say ma'am
would you please come with us she's like
i didn't do anything no no ma'am please
just come with us
so the woman walks with them and they
take her towards the homeless man on the
bench and as they get closer she starts
thinking oh no
he's dead
he's probably dead of a drug overdose
why do i have to see that i don't want
to see a dead man
and then as she got closer to the bench
she notices the man is not moving and
she thought oh gosh he's been murdered
we have a murderer living in our area
and then she noticed the man was covered
with a blanket the only part of his body
that was showing was his feet
which were bare
but that's so odd she thought it's cold
outside why wouldn't he cover his feet
and as she looked closer
she noticed something very strange
it looked like
there were holes in the middle of his
feet
and she gasped and she took a step back
and the police said ma'am
it's okay
it's only a statue
well i don't like it she said take it
away
i don't like it
as you can see
this is the statue homeless jesus
it is the work of a canadian sculptor
named timothy schmaltz
he created this work because he felt the
need to visually represent christ's
presence in every person in every place
and after he finished the sculpture
which as you can see is pretty life-like
well he offered it to saint matthews in
downtown toronto and they said
oh you know no i don't think so thanks
anyway
and then he offered it
to um
the cathedral the cathedral in
washington dc and they said
it doesn't really fit with our image
he offered it to st patrick's in new
york and the same thing he offered it
everywhere no one wanted it finally the
city of toronto said
we'll take it
that's how it ended up
on a bench
outside or across the street
from this woman's house
in 2013.
hundreds of people walk by this statue
every day and never notice it at all
they never see
the feet that are uncovered
they never see the nail marks that are
in the feet
and those who have noticed well they
started a campaign
to get them
removed the statue creeps me out one guy
said
it needs to go
jesus would not sleep on a bench he said
after all he's god
it's tempting isn't it
to look for jesus to to experience jesus
in the places we want to experience him
to get to know him only in the good
places
the highs of our lives
it's tempting to follow him up the
mountain and believe
that that's where he'll stay
it's also tempting in those times to
look for jesus anywhere that we've met
him before those wonderful places we've
experienced his power and his glory we
want to keep climbing because we believe
that the mountain is the best place to
find him
we want to keep him there
where we can bask in his glory
we'd rather
go from that glory
straight to the glory of the
resurrection
many of us try don't we
it's easier that way
easier
much less scary
but but see while we're focused on that
easy we fail to notice
that jesus is going back down the
mountain
back to work
back to a broken world
headed for the cross
and if we really want to get to know
jesus
we have to follow him down the mountain
we have to follow him all the way to the
cross and on the way on the journey we
have to expect to meet him in new ways
and different places
we have to open our eyes to see that
jesus is not basking in glory but at
work in the world in the good and the
bad
he's at work in our happiest moments and
he's at work where there's pain and
darkness and suffering and despair
and we have to understand that
maybe god gives us those transfiguration
moments so that in those places of
darkness and despair we can see a
glimmer of glory
and recognize christ
those times were where we felt that god
is conspicuously absent or silent like
we went one way and god went the other
way well
maybe
we can see him
in a homeless man sleeping on a bench
in a poor single mother struggling to
make ends meet
and a woman who sits in a jail cell
a teen disowned by his parents
a woman oppressed by a religion
that she didn't choose
an african child that has to drink dirty
water
and any other place where people are
hurting and suffering
this evening that's the jesus i invite
you to meet
that's the jesus i invite you to get to
know
to draw closer to him and the only way
we can do it is follow him all the way
to the cross
we have to go through those valleys if
we're to know him at all
it's not an easy journey
but it's so important
and if we choose not to take it the
chances are we're going to go through
our entire lives and never experience
the true glory
of jesus christ
never know the richness of a real
relationship with the one who suffered
and died
all for us
we've experienced him on the mountain
and it was life changing
now tonight i invite you to come down
the mountain
and ask yourselves
where is jesus
looking
to meet you
would you pray with me
loving god
we are so tempted to look for you and
only the good
to think that we can only experience you
in the highs of life
but god
you have shown us through your son
where you are willing to go
and who
you are present in every single person
god open our eyes
so that we might see your image and
those we don't want to see it in
that we might know your presence
in places we might not want to go
that we might know
however
that wherever we go
you are with us
now
and forevermore
amen
we're going to close out with
a song that you guys have probably heard
many many times um but i love carter
played this a while back at the very
beginning of the pandemic and it's just
been something i've always loved this
song but it's stuck
in my head and lately just as different
people have gone through very trying
situations in our life it's one that
just continues to come back and i find
hope in it so i hope it's something that
gives you guys some hope tonight too
[Music]
blackbird singing in the dead of night
take these broken wings and learn to fly
all your life
you were only waiting for this moment to
arrive
[Music]
blackbird singing in the dead of night
take these sunken eyes and learn to sing
all your life
you were only waiting
[Music]
in the dark
night
[Music]
blackbird flying
black knight
[Music]
blackbird singing in the dead of night
take these broken wings and learn to fly
[Music]
all your life
you were only waiting for this moment to
rise
arise
you were only waiting for this moment to
arrive
thank you carter
thanks you guys
thank you so much for being here tonight
denise thank you that was a
beautiful message
um and what a gift to be connected to
you and your church community it just
feels like extended family so we're
really really grateful uh i hope that
the service
all of it touched you uh we're so glad
you are here uh here and those that
joined us online tonight if you're
visiting with us
online please leave a comment so that we
can connect with you at some point this
week and if we have any visitors here
tonight we have
some cards just as you leave this door
in the back there are some little
cards with pens if you could just write
down your name and a way to get in
contact with you we would love to be
able to do that this week and just make
that connection
um
don't forget about halloween trunk or
treat will be taking place instead of
our usual service
and
you can find all this information on our
website thetabletx.org
and i would love to send you out into
your week with a benediction so if you
are comfortable doing so please stand
with me
i hope each of you really hears this for
yourself first and foremost
you are a child of god
you
are a child of god
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts
of love and unconditional grace to
everybody you come in contact with this
week be blessed and we hope to see you
back here next sunday good night
i could see the stars dancing with the
moonlight kill
i